人は突然変異で成功者にはなりません。
まさに人的資本経営っていうか人を大切に
する経営の共感共感してる人を採用してる
よね。どんなに口で言ったって言葉じゃ
ないんだよ。行為は有便に語っているので
青木サの人生学100回聞いたら豊かに
なる話。
今回はですね、採用に関する質問でございまして、使用期間中に絶対に見極めるべきことや見落としてしまうとその後にリスクになる特徴はありますかという質問でございます。
なるほど。
これね、ナポレオンヒルというね、ま、世界の成功の研究をした歴史的人物ですよね。
ナポレヒルは配偶者選びと仲間選びは警戒
しなさいって言ってるんですよ。で、それ
は何がポイントかって言うと、1度仲間に
してしまうと後戻りできない状態になる
可能性がある。結婚もそうですよね。でも
あんまり警戒してないよな。恋愛してね
[笑い]。お互い深い関係になったら
なんか知らないけどずるずるみたいな結婚
が多いじゃん。これはもう無計画は失敗を
計画してることと同じなんですよ。だから
感情に流されない。だから気をつけなきゃ
いけないのは情に流されるってことです。
これは大事なポイントでもね、人間って
やっぱり情があるんですよ。で、上って
すごく尊いの。その情があるからこそ人が
ついてくるんですよ。ロボットじゃない
から。僕なんかものすごい情会ですよ。
その情に流されて失敗したことも過去多い
だけどこの上優に残った人間が一致団結し
て良い組織を作っているだ。その上等よく
揃と言うんだけどね。僕は正直ね、目先の
尊徳で考えないんだよね。だから例えば
あの雨の日の友というような言葉があるん
だけど人が窮地にいる時にこそ力になって
あげようとかまそういう生き方を貫いてき
たんですね。ただ採用に関しては絶対に
入り口管理しなきゃだめです。じゃあま、
具体的に言うとマインドノハウ
スキルなんですよ。人は突然変異で成功者
にはなりません。ですからまず1番大事な
ことは事実、実績。ま、言うなれば例えば
裁判になった時に証拠とか誰かの発言に
おいても必ず裏付けとるじゃん。それは
真実なのかどうかってことだよね。真実と
事実と現実って違うわけじゃん。これいつ
も僕は口癖のように言ってるよね。で、
真実というのは神の水を知る世界なんです
よ。事実は実存の世界なんです[音楽]よ
。で、これはデータ科学者って実は事実に
基づいたエビデンスとかこういうのすごく
重視するんだよね。ま、どっちかっていう
と理系の人ってそういう傾向強いと思い
ます。だ、ロジックも全部実に結びつけて
いくところがその最後の現実っていうのは
人が互感を通して捉えた世界だから印象だ
とかその面接の時の雰囲気だとかその時の
一瞬のパフォーマンスで採用するしないと
決めてしまったり絶対ダメです。だ、僕は
すごくシビアなところがあって、その採用
活動の中で例えば時間をちゃんと守ってる
かとか、報告、連絡、相談の能力とか実務
に入る前の段階の新卒の子なんか特にそう
なんだけど、そういう採用家庭の思考と
行為が一致できてるかどうかを採用判断に
します。採用チームうちは今4人の
メンバーが採用だけに集中してるんですね
。人事の中でも深層採用チームの子。この
子たちの近くを僕は信頼してます。で、
アチューメントっていう会社は営業に回し
ても1億ぐらいの売上をパーソナルで個人
で確実に出せるなって思えるような優秀な
子を実は企画だとか人事だとかそういう
部署に回してるんですよ。これもまたね僕
の独特なところで普通はねお前営業でき
ないんだからお前人事でもやっとけとかね
。お前営業できないんだからそうもやれと
かね。これがダメな経営者なの。それ経営
者に問題があるわけ。それとかね、なん
だろう。お前なんだそんなお前AIとか
なんとか言ってそんな時間ならもうお客の
とこに会いに行けとかね。もうこういうの
もダメ。もう時代はもうね、そ使えない
経営者は浦島太郎です。もうまた問題発言
した。いや、だからねんだろう。全ては
経営者の感覚なんだけども、やっぱり事実
をしっかりと捉えながら倍制度みたいに売
の人たちが有罪無罪って決めるじゃん。
うちの場合は人事チームとかその採用に
関わった人たちがどうしても一緒に働き
たいというそういう人材しか採用しない
会社なんですよ。だからなんだろ、深素
採用に関してはもう1回も面接で採用と
なったら100%採用責任を全倒するので
私たちから手を離すことはないです。絶対
諦めません。だから中途採用に関しては
ぶっちゃけさ、本来優秀な人って前の会社
でもやめないんだよ。そうなんだよ。どこ
にいてもできるんだから。でも点々とする
人間がいるとしたら、ま、これちょっとね
、あまりなんだろう、決めつけちゃだめだ
けど、どうなんだろう。人材流動化って
言うけど、僕はね、よっぽどの
スペシャリストで全職の実績実績実績で
上がってきたら別だけど、ま、正直人材
紹介会社が多少持った話をして少しこう
デコレーションしてどうやって高い報酬で
決めるか、そっからコミッションベースで
彼ら目指してるからそんな話に乗っちゃ
だめだから、やっぱり人物見
るっていうのもね、ちょっと微妙なので、
紹介会社
の話も6ぐらいしか信じちゃだめだな。
じゃ、何がポイントかっていうと、全職に
ちゃんと聞いたらいいんですよ。全職で
どうでしたかねって。前の会社の紹介
もらえるかどうかぐらいのそういう基準だ
と思うよ。だ、私は基本的には有力者紹介
法が1番いいと思います。やっぱり信頼の
おける人の紹介、信用のおける人の紹介。
まず中途採用はそれがメインだよね。あと
は、ま、紹介会社でも、ま、正直紹介会社
の言う言葉はもうほぼねいて、もう履歴書
のトルーというか、実績、真実だけで実績
だけで採用した方がいい。あとあえて言う
ならやっぱり人柄、人間関係、やっぱり
家族を大臣にしてる人っていうのは中途
半端には転職しません。家族のこと大事に
思ってるから。それから全職でもちゃんと
ね、感謝を表す。前の職場で本当に感謝し
てますていうような人は人柄としては問題
ないよね。もう悪口言ったら採用しない方
がいいよ。お前に問題があだろみたいな
もんだよ。いや、絶対そうなんだって。
事実は1つ解釈無数なんだから。大体自己
正当化のストーリーを持ってんだ。人間
っていうのは。そういう言葉は一切信用し
ない方がいいだ。私はあえてね、前の会社
って大変だったんじゃないですかとかって
聞くと、え、そうなんですって出てくんだ
よ、大体へっと。それは能力のなさを表し
てるわけよ。だって大変なものを乗り越え
て人は成長するわけじゃん。挑戦と挫折。
それを乗り越えて成長があり、その先に
サクセスがあるんだよ。
うちの会社で幹部になる人間なんかもうたくさんのプロジェクト背負いながらだってメイだってそうだろ?お前今いくつプロジェクトを担当してんの?
ちょっと数えきれないほど。
数えきれないだろ。ほらもう何年目?今年で
年になります。
拍手アチーブメントで
年務めたら本物です。めちゃんはなんでうちの会社で
10年続いてあなたはねなんだろう。
アチンメントの採用ってどういう風に客観的に見てる?
10年
やっぱりその目的に共感したというところにつきますね。
そうだよな。
はい。
なんだろう。この人材教育でなければならない。そして選択理論、アチューメントテクノロジーを使って縁ある人を幸せにしたい。
そういう意味での、ま、まさにこう
人的資本経営っていうか、人を大切にする
経営の共感共感してる人を採用してるよね
。そういうことなんだろうな。だから
やっぱり目的を持って人を採用することな
んじゃないのかな。ありがとうございます
。
ちなみにその使用期間中というところでいいと、ま、面接ではどうしても見えづらいからこそ使用期間中に特にここを注意深く見ておくべきみたいなポイントってうん。だから人柄でしょ、まずはと思うのことながら約束守れる人間かどうかだよな。それと約束の中には数字があるじゃん。何人に面解しますと言って満立つとか。
それは約束不振不行の人間なんだから信用しちゃだめなんだよ。どんなに口で言ったって言葉じゃないんだよ。行為は有便に語っているのでだ。行動観察で使用期間で見極めるってことじゃないの?
ありがとうございます。
ちなみにその使用期間中にもし気がかりなポイントが見つかった時はどういう風に対応されんですか?
もう使用期間延長するしかないんじゃないの?もしくはなんだろう?それこそ人事と協議をしながらやっぱり採用するかしないかその気がかりなものがアチメントの文化や最も我々が大切にしてるものに対して能力あるけれども入れたら文化壊すかもし
てないねとかそういう場合には不作用だね
。多少能力があっても僕はそういうことを
すごく大事にしてきたんですよ。実はだ徳
で考えてないんだよ俺。なんかこう人を
利益を生み出すための道具みたいに思って
たらどうしてもその能力市場主義になるん
だよね。僕はみんなで共に価値を想像して
きたいっていうタイプなので、やっぱり
仲間があいつとは働きたくないなっていう
人間はなるべく使用期間で入れないように
してきたよな。そういうことなんじゃない
かな。だって気分悪いじゃん。だ、うちの
場合はやっぱりね、批判する、責める、
文句を言う、神々言う、脅す、罰ツを
与える、目先の褒美で釣る。これが一切
ない職場だよね。成長する、支援する、
励ます信頼する、尊重する、そして需要
する。意見の違いについては常に交渉する
。こういうのがいわゆる上下感だけじゃ
なくて横の関係でもこうしてるじゃん。だ
から文化が良くなるわけよ。だ、そういう
人柄の人間とそれでなおかつ裏付けとなる
実績を使期間中ちゃんと約束を果たせる。
ま、うちで言うと報酬を最初決めたらその
報酬と、ま、自由の代下は責任だからね。
報酬といわゆるこの期間だけのことをやり
ますって言ったそこのことをちゃんと
バランスがあるわけだから、例えば、え、
4件、8件、16件とかね、例えばだよ。
契約の件数があるとしたらその言ったこと
をちゃんと果たせるかどうかっていうこれ
は手型を振り振り出してもふ当たりを出す
ような経営者に金貸さないじゃん。同じ
ロジックだと思うよ。だそこはやっぱり
あまりにも人間関係の方にあの触れすぎ
ない方がいい。ここはもうとっても大事な
ポイントだと人はね変異で成功者になら
ないんですよ。
人柄とあとはやっぱり能力。それとま、
シンプルに誠実って約束守ることなんで
約束をこごとく全部守れる人間を採用し
たらいい。それから情に流されないことだ
ね。うん。しっかりと実を見て採用する。
あとは長期的、本質的、客観的にその人を
見て仲間として一生共にやっていきたいか
。それぐらいの気持ちで採用する。ま、
本当に本音本心でアチューメントが
取り組んできたことをそのまんま話をし
ました。参考にしていただければ幸いです
。え、是非コメント欄に何かあったら
コメントください。そしてチャンネル登録
もね、是非していただければ嬉しいです。
次回のまたYouTubeで会いましょう
。ありがとうございます。
僕も実は38年経用してきて失敗した例が
あるのよ。
で、その失敗ってね、本質的じゃない。意思決定した時だよね。いや、それどういうことかって言うと、僕はあの北海道出身に弱いわけね。うん。
はい。
だからクリスチャンに弱いんだよ。あとね、選択理論に出会って良くなりましたって言われちゃうとね、これも微妙にね、なんかね、上が入るんだ。その時に本質的ではない意思決定をしてる。で、投資でもそうなんだよ。
受行性だからと言って必ずしも経営で成功
するわけじゃないでしょ。でもやっぱり
受行性に対して支援してあげたいと思う
から出資をしてあげたりする。ま、過去
それで随分なんだ失敗と思ってないよ。で
もま、ある意味では報われない思いをした
ことはあるよね。うちの息子なんかはあの
面白いこと言ってね。自分でも起業してる
んだけど、彼はあの個人投資家もしてたん
で僕に言ってたのはパパね、投資をするの
はもうこれから上場しようとするところに
投資するよりもすでに上場して現在良い
仕事をしていて社会の後期にもなりだけど
今の世の中の市場環境の中で政党に評価さ
れない本来力のある会社が一時的に株価が
下がってるようなところ、そういうところ
の株を所有した方が将来上がるじゃないと
。なんでこれから上場しようとするような
ところの人とか意欲はあっても実績のない
人の応援なんでするのって昔言われたこと
あるんだよ。まあこれ的てるよね。だ、
それはやっぱり上なんですよ。
決して負けない[音楽]経営だ。まず経営
者自身が
お金よりも仕事の内容そのものに掘れ込ん
でるかどうかなです。
[音楽]